logiquement au soleil couchant le calme
ne revient sur l'île charlemagne
il semble pourtant que ce soit l'inversé
en ce samedi soir
la nuit est tombée l'ambiance monte
c'est l'effet no limit racing quand il
fallait qu'on s'élève à nos limites
ville de cenon avec départ de nuit et
comme vous pouvez le voir c'est assez
fantastique puisque c'est une ambiance
géniale
et puis je pense que les gens vont bien
s'amuser les copains d'orléans sportifs
de l'extrême ont sorti la tenue de gala
pour cette grande occasion pour l'aja
fait deux jours et là c'est la première
qu'on fait de nuit non c'est pour été
c'est impossible de faire marche arrière
sept kilomètres à pied une vingtaine
d'obstacles à franchir avancer coûte que
coûte
il faut s'imposer dans une nature
parfois hostile chacun son style le
principal finalement c'est de progresser
et nos héros progressent ensemble il
faut faire honneur au tutu et à gilbert
la mascotte fidèles compagnons de galère
tout donné dans la bonne humeur générale
on rigole on s'amuse et qui voyons-nous
surgir dans cette nuit noire
réponse de 7 km avec les amis entre la
boue le sable et les obstacles on a bien
équipé et on a ramené notre gilbert
anticiper et à la fin de la denture tout
le monde a bien mérité sa médaille
même gilbert manado nord non
la famille